as coronavirus cases thirds around the
country there is a new focus on young
people who make up a growing number of
infections some are partying at beaches
and bars like there is no pandemic at
all in Michigan for example health
officials say 113 Kovach 19 cases are
now linked to just one reopened bar in
Ingham County those infected range in
age from 18 to 28 years old the
definition of young David Beck now is
looking into how young people's
attitudes about the virus may be fueling
its spread he's in Miami Beach which is
a coronavirus hotspot of course David
good morning some young people just do
not seem to be taking this seriously
what did you learn well some are and
you'll hear from them in a moment
look Tony I was flying from California
to Florida yesterday when the governor
mentioned young people and how he
thought them interacting was
contributing to the spread of the virus
just last night the mayor of miami-dade
County signed an order closing all
restaurants of eight or more people
because he said they were turning into
bars after midnight this story is not to
preach at young people but we went and
got the facts for you we talked to a
doctor and we also listened to young
people watch from the West Coast in San
Francisco it's not going to really stop
me from like
going out to the East Coast in Boston I
just personally don't care I haven't got
sick yet and down south in Atlanta I'm
definitely seeing a lot fewer people
wearing masks young people are out
enjoying the warmer weather but
according to health officials they might
also be spreading and contracting the
corona virus as people pack into parks
beaches restaurants bars and even
concerts cases are rising in at least 37
states with surges among young people
linked to everything from fitness
classes to summer fraternity parties
they may be indirectly are hurting
people by infecting someone who then
infects someone who then infects someone
who is vulnerable in Arizona nearly half
of the corona virus cases are people
twenty to forty four years old last week
President Trump held a rally in the
state where a crowd of around 3,000
people were mostly young and maskless in
Hays County Texas about 30 miles outside
of Austin young adults make up more than
half of all cases in the state of
Florida which is a corona virus hotspot
the highest number of cases are among
people between the ages of 25 and 34
years old if I get it then you live with
your consequences
Boyan odd enough zovsky lives in West
Palm Beach Florida the 25 year old
salesman told us he wears a mask in
places where it's required but he
doesn't want coronavirus to stop him
from living life I need something to
unwind as some people like reading some
people like working no I like you know
going and seeing other people as well
now if if I had to go out and do that
with a face mask right if they required
it to wear a face mask sure I'll do that
um but if they don't require it I would
choose not to what have you observed
over the last few weeks as it pertains
into code with 19 in Florida the age of
cases is what is most remarkable that
has been dropping steadily dr. Charles
Lockwood is senior vice president of
University of South Florida Health
he's administered more than 300
coronavirus tests himself and he is
alarmed by the spike among young people
it really is it's just
what we've been observing which is
incredible non-compliance with wearing
face masks social distancing
particularly among young adults and
teenagers as a doctor are you at a point
where you still are trying to get
through to those people I think we need
to accept the fact that young folks have
a different way of looking at life the
problem is that while you may not die
and you may not even know you're sick
you may be killing other people if my
parents really act like I would sophia
carry own lives with her parents in Los
Angeles and she says she's strict about
social distancing and wearing the mask
the 23 year old has a message to other
young people who were not taking the
virus as seriously yeah it's not just
about you like oh if I get it like I'll
be fine maybe but you don't want to pass
it to someone who could be more you know
I was watching an interview yesterday
with an ICU doctor here in Miami who
said the patient's he's treating today
are younger and they're sicker here's a
fact for you from Florida to 17-year
olds have died here and I was just
reading the story of one of them her
name was Carson
she had dealt with cancer as a child and
so we wear a mask for people like her
for our parents our grandparents Gayle
we do it for our colleague Cindy who's
with us this morning on this live shot
the audio engineer who survived breast
cancer we do it for them in hopes that
they'll do it for us I know Cindy you're
absolutely right I say this David we
were all young people once you're still
a young person but we were all young
people so if you don't want to do it for
yourself do you love your mom your dad
your grandma please do it for them this
is such I think we need to figure out a
way to have Anthony Fouts you on a loop
somewhere playing over and over and over
again this is very serious stuff thank
you David very much and hello to Cindy